mios-biganos bassin d'arcachon face au
havre en bleu un quart de finale de
coupe de la ligue féminine de handball
explosif à plaisir au palais des sports
pierre de coubertin le suspense aura
duré jusqu'à la dernière seconde
et c'est pourtant l'équipe du havre de
la gardienne linda pradel natif de
trappes qui prend le meilleur départ
quelques buts signés anna de souza donne
le ton presque à domicile
celle qui évolue également en équipe de
france doit faire face au relâchement de
ses coéquipières après la pause à
égalité après sept minutes les deux
équipes jouent au chat et à la souris
c'est l'international serbe jovana
stojkovic qui arrache l'avantagent pour
le havre 26 25
et c'est le havre qui va s'imposer grâce
à ça car diem justement linda pradel
elle signe son sixième et ultime arrêt
de la rencontre sur ce coup de sifflet
final de l'arbitré
super bien accueilli c'est vrai que ben
voilà avec le sport on l'a pas trop
l'occasion de revenir un petit peu voir
la famille et tout donc là ça va être
quelque part tout le monde
l'organisation linda pradel et le havre
sur le terrain d'ici paris pour la
demi-finale rencontre programmée jeudi
soir et une volonté de l'emporter pour
les normandes d'autant plus forte qu'en
février
elle était éliminé de la coupe d'europe
pour les instances locales l'opération
séduction est en tout cas un succès la
rencontre a permis d'accueillir quelques
1200 personnes
reste à voir les incidences sur les
inscriptions dans les clubs dans les
prochains mois actuellement elles sont
2000 à jouer au hand dans les yvelines